quand les parents disparaissent
il ne nous laisse que quelques vieilles
photos et des questions sans réponses
ont grandi sans savoir
j'ai imaginé mes parents ensemble au
temps où ils s'aimaient alors j'ai
ouvert la valise de ma mère
la valise des secrets il ne me restait
plus qu'à les faire revivre tout cas
sony music et le confrère c'est pas
possible les morts dans les camps il
arrive de moscou je pensais que tu étais
moi aussi je pense que demain tu es sûr
que c'est ton frère
l actu pense que c'est une taupe toi est
ce que tu penses
ça vous piratez communiste ait
démissionné elle est belle elle est là
la première fois que j'ai vu j'ai su que
c'était la femme de ma vie est elle à
penser que l'homme de sa vie puis quand
tu fais tout ce qui te dit attends tu
fais pour tout ce qui
que
hahaha
et lille vous le connaissez pas non plus
la marche et déserteurs espion c'est
quoi la vérité c'est pourquoi son
bordeaux par aures que des types comme
toi au zoo pas couché que la femme de
mon frère et des bêtises qu'on regrette
de pas avoir fait c'est ton frère ça à
mon frère
on grandit tant bien que mal entre les
non-dits et les questions sans réponse
puis un jour on regarde enfants ses
parents comme un homme et une femme
qu'on aurait croisé dans nos vies et
qu'on aurait aimé simplement pour ceux
qu'ils s'étaient